it's
[Music]
assalamu
alayum we welcome all of you to this
eighth Day evening session of the 10-day
International Islamic conference and
exhibition We Begin today's session with
the Kat by shikh Salah Abdul Rahman
albat from
[Music]
UA
[Applause]
[Music]
Al
for
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
ja now we have the translation of the
karat being presented by Brother Jamal
Richards from London United Kingdom
brother
[Music]
Jamal
in the name of Allah most gracious most
merciful the hour has come near and the
moon has split in two and if they see a
sign they turn away and say passing
magic and they denied and followed their
incarnations but for every matter is a
time of
settlement and there has already come to
them of information that in which there
is
deterrence extensive wisdom but warning
does not Avail
them so leave them oh Muhammad the day
the caller calls to something
forbidden their eyes humbled they will
emerge from the graves as if they were
Locust
spreading racing ahead towards the
the disbelievers will say this is a
difficult
day the people of Noah denied before
them and they denied our servant and
said a madman and he was
repelled so he invoked his Lord indeed I
am overpowered so
help then we opened the gates of the
heaven with rain pouring down and caused
the Earth to burst with springs and the
the waters met for a matter already
predestined and we carried him on a
construction of planks and
Nails sailing under our observation as
reward for he who had been
denied and we left it as a sign so is
there any who will
remember and how severe Were My
Punishment and
warning and we have certainly made the
Quran easy for remembrance so is there
any who will
remember and add denied and how severe
Were My Punishment and
mning indeed we sent upon them a
screaming wind on a day of continuous
Misfortune extracting the people as if
they were trunks of palm trees
uprooted and how severe Were My
Punishment and
warning and we have certainly made the
Quran easy for remembrance so is is
there any who will
remember samud denied the warning and
said is it one human being Among Us that
we should follow indeed we would then be
in error and
madness has the message being sent down
upon him from Among Us rather he is an
insolent
liar indeed we are sending the she camel
as a trial for them so watch them and be
patient and inform them that the water
is shared between them each day of drink
attended by
turn but they called their companion and
he dared and hamstrung her and how
severe Were My Punishment and
warning indeed we sent upon them one
shriek a blast from the sky and they
became like the dry twig fragments of an
animal
pen and we have certainly made the Quran
easy for remembrance so is there any who
will
remember the people of lot denied the
warning indeed we sent upon them a storm
of stones except the family of lot we
saved them before
Dawn as favor from us thus do we reward
he who is
grateful and he had already warned them
of our assault but they disputed the
warning and they demanded from him his
guests but we obliterated their eyes
saying Taste My Punishment and
warning and They Came Upon them by
mourning and abiding
punishment so Taste My Punishment and
warning and we have certainly made the
Quran easy for remembrance so is there
any who will
remember and there certainly came to the
people of pharaoh warning they denied
our signs all of them so we seized them
with a seizure of exalted in might and
perfect
inability are your disbelievers better
than those former ones or have you
immunity in the
scriptures or do they say we are an
assembly supporting each
other their assembly will be defeated
and they will turn their backs in
retreat but the hour is their
appointment for due punishment and the
hour is more disastrous and more bitter
indeed the criminals are in error and
Madness
the day they are dragged into the fire
on their faces it will be said taste the
touch of
Saka indeed all things we created with
predestination and our Command is but
one like a glance of the eye and we have
already destroyed your kinds so is there
any who will
remember and everything they did is in
written records and every small and
great thing is inscribed
indeed the righteous will be among
Gardens and rivers in a seat of Honor
near a sovereign perfect
inability
jazak brother Jamal Richards for your
translation now we start the formal
public talk session our speaker for
today needs no introduction to many
present here but for those who would not
know about him
I present the formal
introduction Dr Zakir NY is the
president of the Islamic Research
Foundation a medical doctor by
professional training he is renowned as
a dynamic International orator on Islam
and comparative
religion Dr Zakir clarifies Islamic
viewpoints and clears misconceptions
about Islam using the Quran authentic
Hadith and other religious scriptures in
conjunction with reason logic and
scientific
facts he's 44 years old Dr Zakir is
popular for his critical analysis and
convincing answers to challenging
questions posed by audiences and critics
after his public talks in the last 13
years Dr Zakir has delivered more than
1300 public talks in Far Away places as
USA Canada UK Saudi Arabia UAE Kuwait
Qatar Bahrain Oman South Africa Italy
macius Australia Malaysia Singapore Hong
Kong Thailand Guyana South America
Trinidad and Tobago and many other
countries in addition to numerous public
talks in India
too he has successfully participated in
several symposia and dialogues with
prominent personalities of other
faiths the late shik Ahmed
datat the world famous orator on Islam
and comparative religion a Pioneer in
his field who had called Dr Zakir datat
Plus in 1994 presented a plague in May
2000 with an engraved citation on it
awarded to Dr Zakir Abdul Karim n for
his achievement in the field of dawa and
the study of comparative religion and he
went on further to say
son what you have done in the last four
years had taken me 40 years to
accomplish alhamdulillah Dr Zakir
appears regularly on many International
television channels in more than 200
countries worldwide he's regularly
invited for TV and radio interviews
hundreds of his talks dialogues debates
and symposia are available on vcds DVDs
and other digital and internet media
peace
TV is his passionate and professional
far-reaching presentation of Islam to
Muslims and non-muslims world worldwide
he has authored books on Islam and
comparative religion the more popular
ones being Quran and modern science
compatible or incompatible wom's rights
in Islam protected or subjugated concept
of God in major religions and answers to
non-muslims common questions about Islam
brothers and sisters to speak to us
today on a vital topic Al Quran should
it be read with understanding may I
present before you Dr Zakir
[Music]
Nik
alhamdulillah
my respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters I welcome all of you with
the Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of almighty
God be on all of
you the topic of this evening's talk is
alquran should it be read with
understanding the Glorious Quran is the
last and final
revelation of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of
almighty God which was revealed to the
last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon
him the Glorious Quran is the most
positive book in the world it is a
proclamation to humanity it is a
fountain of mercy and wisdom it is a
guide to the erring it is a warning to
the
heedless an assurance to those in doubt
it's a Solace to the suffering and it is
a hope to those in
despair how is it possible to derive all
these benefits of the Quran without
reading the
Quran without understanding the
Quran without pondering over the meaning
of the Quran and without implementing
the Quran in your
life alhamdulillah the Glorious Quran is
the most widely read book in the
world but unfortunately it is also the
book which is most widely read without
understanding because the majority of
the Muslims read the Quran without
understanding that's the reason the
contact
the benefit that the Muslims derive from
the Quran it has
decreased the touch of the Muslim of the
Quran has
declined imagine if a person comes to
the
Quran and he goes away
empty-handed Hearts
untouched soul
unmoved and the life
unchanged what a tragic Misfortune it is
Allah says in the Quran inah Al Imran
chapter number three verse number
110 oh Muslims ye are the best of people
the all for
mankind because we enjoy what is good
and we forbid what is wrong and we
believe in
Allah Allah is calling us the Muslims
the the best of people evolve for
humankind and the reason he's giving us
is because we enjoy what is good and we
forbid what is wrong and we believe in
Allah if we
Muslims read the Quran without
understanding how can we enjoy what is
good and forbid what is wrong and if we
do not enjoy what is good and if we do
not forbid what is wrong we aren't fit
to be called as Muslims we aren't fit to
be called
as so if we want to be called as
if we want to be Muslims we have to read
the Quran with understanding so that we
can enjoy what is good and forbid what
is
wrong the Arabic what
Quran is derived from the
Arabic which means book it's also
derived from the Arabic word which means
to read which means to
recite which means to
Proclaim how can we proclaim the message
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala without
understanding the
message and another title given to Quran
is foran that is the criteria to judge
right from wrong we can only
judge between right and wrong if we
understand the message of the
Quran without understanding the message
of the Quran it's not possible that we
can use the Quran as the foran as the
criteria to judge between right and
wrong let's analyze today the various
excuses given by us Muslims for not
reading the Quran with
understanding the most common excuse
is we do not know Arabic as a
language today the world population is
approximately 6
billion and about 20 to 25% of the world
population are Muslim about 1.3 to 1.5
billion Muslims are there in the world
and out of the Muslim population
approximately 15% are
Arabs and there are very few non-arabs
who understand Arabic as language so
amongst the Muslim population more than
80% of the Muslims they don't understand
Arabic as a language so the most common
excuse that we Muslims have not to read
the Quran with understanding is we do
not know Arabic as a language
langage when a human being is
born he does not know any language the
child he initially learns the mother
tongue so that he can converse with the
family
members later
on he may learn the language of the
society so that he could communicate
with the people around
him he may learn the language in which
he's
educated
almost all the human beings they at
least know two or three different
languages some know three to five
languages some are
linguists but most of the human beings
almost all they at least know two to
three different
languages isn't it a
requirement that we should know the
language in which our creat Allah
subhana wa ta'ala has revealed his last
and final message the Glorious Quran
isn't it a
must that we Muslims should learn Arabic
as a language to understand the
Quran I know that it is much
easier for a person to learn a language
during
childhood but age is never a
barrier to prevent any human being from
doing any good work
and that reminds me of the example of Dr
Morris
BK many of you may be aware that Dr
Morris BK was a very famous surgeon and
scientist who was given the French
Academy Award in
medicine and Dr Morris Bale he was
selected for doing
research on the mummy of
manapa that is the mummy of the body of
pharaoh who was there at the time of
Moses peace be upon him which is
mentioned in the
Bible and after he did
research on this mmy of manapa which was
found in the valley of
Kings he being a
Christian he was
aware of the background mention of Moses
peace be upon him in the
Bible and he was aware
that the Pharaoh at the time of Moses
peace be upon him when he followed Moses
peace be upon him when he parted the sea
and when he followed
him the sea again came back to normal
and the Pharaoh had
drowned but when he went to Saudi
Arabia there he learned that the Muslims
told
him that the Quran already mentions in
Sur yunus chapter number 10 what verse
number 92
that Allah says we shall save the body
of the Pharaoh as a sign for
posterity Dr Morris buk he was shocked
that how does this book The Glorious
Quran 1400 years back says that almighty
God Will Save the body of pharaoh as a
sign for posterity as a sign for
humankind and this is not mentioned in
the Bible so that instigated him to read
the translation of the
Quran and after he read the translation
of the Quran he was so much inspired
that he wanted to understand the Quran
better so at the age of 50 he learned
Arabic as a language to understand the
Quran better imagine a
non-muslim a Christian to understand the
Quran better he learns Arabic as a
language and after he does research he
says that the scientific point points
mentioned in the Quran are in perfect
confirmity with what modern science have
discovered and unfortunately there are
many things in the Bible which do not
confirm with modern
science and after doing further research
he writes a book The Bible the Quran and
science which became very
famous the point to be noted here
is imagine a person of the age of 50
being a non-muslim being a Christian to
understand the Quran better he learns
Arabic as
language so we
Muslims the best excuse we have is that
we don't know Arabic as a
language I do not expect every Muslim to
be as enthusiastic
as Dr Morris
B that they'd like to learn Arabic at
the age of 50
but even if a Muslim does not know
Arabic as a language yet he has got no
excuse because he can yet read the
translation of the Quran and
alhamdulillah the Quran has been
translated into most of the major
languages of the
world Malana Abdul Maadi
say the Quran is the most untranslatable
book in the
world the language of the Quran is so
pure it is divine it is Noble it is
unsurpassable it is
intelligible and that the reason it
makes Quran the most difficult book to
translate not only does it make it the
most difficult book to translate in fact
it is a book which is impossible to
translate yet alhamd
there are many scholars who have spent
several years who have spent decades in
doing
research and have translated the
Glorious
Quran into most of the major languages
of the
world even though I agree that no
translation is 100% perfect because a
translation is a human handiwork and the
Arabic
Quran is the word of almighty God the
Creator but in spite of that these
translations at least they let us
understand the basic message of the
Quran the basic message of our creator
Allah subhana wa ta'ala
we
Muslims we give
excuses for not reading the translation
of the Quran saying we are very
busy we are very busy in our studies
we are busy in our profession we are
busy in our
business most of us we have
spend
decades reading and memorizing volumes
of books in schools and colleges as well
as universities just to acquire a
degree don't we have the time to read
the message of our cre Allah subhana wa
ta'ala
how much time does it take to read the
Quran our beloved Prophet M wasallam
said in he said that Anyone who reads
the Quran in less than 3 days he has not
understood the Quran that means if we
read the Quran with concentration it
will minimum take a person 3 days
minimum if you read a bit slowly it may
take five days if you read one J one
part a day it will take you one month to
read the Quran
the degree that we acquire in the
colleges and
universities it may or may not help you
in this world there are hundreds and
thousands of graduates and postgraduates
that I know that are
jobless and the education you acquire in
school colleges and universities if it
does not get you closer to Allah subhana
wa ta'ala if it does not get you closer
to your creator almighty God then this
education is useless for the
Hereafter so the education that you get
in the colleges in the schools and
universities may or may not help you in
this world and if it does not get you
closer to your create Allah subhana wa
ta'ala it is useless in the
Hereafter but as far as the Quran is
concerned Allah says in the
Quran in Surah Bak chapter number two
both number one and
two
this is a book of guidance without doubt
for those who have tawa for those who
fear Allah subhana tala that means Allah
is giving us a promise that this book is
a book of
guidance and it will surely benefit you
in this world as well as Hereafter Allah
says in the Quran in Surah chapter
number 18 verse number
54 that this is a book which mentioned
in
detail many
similitudes in which is benefit for
humankind but men is in most things
contentious Allah repeats a similar
message in Surah aumar chapter number 39
verse number
27 that Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
mentioned in detail many
similitudes so that men may receive
admonish if you read the Quran it will
surely benefit you in this world as well
as Hereafter you read the Quran if you
don't know Arabic read the Quran in the
language you
understand if you understand English
read in English the language you
understand the best if you understand
Udu read it in Udu if you understand
Hindi read it in Hindi if you understand
French read it in French if you
understand German read in German read it
in the language you understand
irrespective whether you read the
English translation the uddu translation
the Hindi translation the French
translation or German translation at
least read the translation of the
Glorious Quran so that you can
understand the message of your
creator I like to give you an
example suppose a very close friend of
yours who's a German he comes from
Germany and he spends a couple of weeks
with you in
Bombay he being a German he can't speak
English fluently but he can converse
with you he spends a couple of weeks in
mombay and when he goes back to Germany
he writes to you a letter in
German because he can't speak English
fluently he can't write English fluently
so he writes to you a letter in German
now when you get that letter in German
you don't understand German
what will you do but natural because
he's a close friend you will have that
letter translated you'll want to know
what did your good friend tell you from
Germany you will have that letter
translated don't you want to
know what is the message the last and
final message given by a cre Allah
subhana wa ta'ala you don't have to go
and translate the Quran the Quran
alhamdulillah has already been
translated in the major languages of the
world many
Muslims they
think that the
Quran was only revealed for the
Muslims and the Quran is not meant for
the
non-muslims Allah says in the Quran in
ibraim chapter number 14 verse number
one Al Lam ra
this is a book which Allah has revealed
so that thou May guid the humankind from
the depth of Darkness to light Allah is
telling that this book the Quran was
revealed to Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him so that he could guide the
humankind from the depth of Darkness to
light Allah says in the Quran in Surah
ibraim chapter number 14 verse number 52
that here is a message for mankind let
them take warning there from let them
know there is one God let the men of
understanding take
heed Quran says in Bak CH number 2 verse
185 Ramadan is the month in which the
Quran was revealed as a guide for
humankind as a criteria to judge right
from wrong the Quran is a book which was
revealed in the month of Ramadan as a
guide for the whole of humankind not
only for the Muslims or for the Arabs
but for the whole of humankind as a
criteria to judge right from wrong
Allah says in Surah alumur chapter
number 39 verse number 41 we have
revealed the message to thee Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him so that thou
May instruct the humankind the Quran
does not say that the Quran was revealed
to Prophet Muhammad so that he may
instruct only the Muslims or the Arabs
so that he may instruct the whole of
humankind yet there are many
Muslims who do not want to share the
Quran with the non Muslims thinking what
will these non-muslims understand the
Quran these non-muslims these mush these
kafir what will they understand the
Quran thinking that they are very
Superior do you know this Quran was
revealed, 1400 years
ago at a time it was revealed in Arabia
at a time which was known as J the days
of
ignorance at that
time before the Quran was revealed the
Arabs were known as the most ignorant
people of the world and imagine this
Quran has changed the lives of these
Arabs and made them the toch bearers of
the
world so when the Quran could change
those people 400 years ago why can't the
Quran change the non-muslims of this
time these are not the days of ignorance
history tells us that was known
as the days of
ignorance Allah says in the Quran inia
chapter number 21 verse number
107 that we have sent thee not but as a
mercy to the whole of humankind as a
mercy to all the creatures as a mercy to
all the worlds Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him was not sent only for the
Muslims or the Arabs the last and final
messenger was sent for the whole of
humankind the Quran says in chapter
number
34 we have sent thee not but as a
universal messenger giving glad Tiding
and warning them against
sin but most of the human beings yet do
not
know so Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him was not sent only for the Muslims or
the Arabs he was sent for the whole of
humankind we
Muslims we
unfortunately want to sit on the Quran
like a cobra neither do we read it
neither do we want the others to read it
and many of the
Muslims they quote the Quran saying that
Quran cannot be given to the non-muslim
because Allah says in the Quran and they
quote
Sur chapter number 56 verse number 77 to
80 where it
says that this is the
Quran which is kept in a tablet well
preserved who None Shall touch except
those who are
pure it is from The Lord of the
worlds and many Muslims say that see the
Quran says None Shall touch the Quran
except those are pure and the
non-muslims they n they napak they
unclean that's the reason these
non-muslims they cannot touch the
Quran if we read the nul Quran why were
these verses
revealed we come to
know
that the mushrik and the kufar of Makkah
they laid allegation that this
Quran are the words of the Satan the
words of shatan Allah reveals
this that none can touch the Arabic word
used
this that means a book well
preserved this kabon does not refer to
this glorious
Quran this book Quran in Arabic is
called as a
mus what the Quran is referring to if
read cross
reference of Sur B chapter number 85
verse number 2122 which says that Allah
has kept the Quran in a tablet well
preserved
inim so this Quran which is being
referred is referred to
the the tablet well preserved the book
well preserved it's not talking about
this
Quran because if it was this Quran
and if the Arabic word use mutar that it
means that only body
cleanliness then any non-muslim can
easily go to the marketplace and buy a
copy of the Quran for 150 rupees for2
200 rupees for $4 for $5 and the Quran
will be proved
wrong the mutar word used does not refer
only to body
cleanliness it refers to a person who's
pure in heart in mind in Soul personals
sinless referring to the angels that
none will be able to touch the Quran in
the tablet well preserved except the
Angels trying to give a reply to the
allegations of the mush of Makkah that
this
Quran was not the words of the
Satan so this verse of the Quran does
not indicate
that a person should be pure in body if
he it's good it is must alhamdulillah
but it's not a
must and
furthermore even if it was a requirement
imagine even if it was a requirement if
a person's shik can be removed from his
life even if you consider this as a
small mistake to touch the Quran without
woo yet removing the shik which is the
biggest sin in
Islam to do a small mistake to remove
the biggest sin in Islam it is yet a
very good
bargain but the scholars of T they say
this verse does not refer and does not
indicate that a person should be in
[Music]
woodoo to touch the Quran but being in
woodoo is good it is alhamdulillah but
not a
must there are many people many Muslims
who tell me okay brother
Zak give the Quran to the non-muslim but
only give the English translation don't
give the Arabic text or give the Hindi
translation the Udu translation I've got
no problem if someone only gives the
translation of the Quran but I
personally prefer giving the Arabic text
along with the translation why because
the translation is the work of a human
being and no human being is
perfect as I mentioned earlier that no
translation is perfect and if there is a
mistake in the translation it will not
be attributed to Allah subhana wa tala
because if we check it up with the
Arabic text besides the translation we
can easily verify that if there's a
mistake in the translation it is the
work of the human being and not of Allah
subhana tala so I personally prefer
giving along with the translation the
Arabic text so that if there is a
mistake Allah subhana wa ta'ala
he'll not be responsible it is the
responsibility of the
translator and furthermore if Allah
holds me responsible I will be in good
company I'll be the company of the
Beloved Prophet mallalli wasallam why
because if you read the theory of the
Prophet M
wasallam he dictated letters to
non-muslim Kings in which he
dictated vers of the Quran he told the
sahabas he dictated letters to
non-muslim Kings in which he dictated
vers of the Quran he sent letters to
nigas of ABIA to Emperor Heracles
emperor of Persia king of Yemen king of
Egypt many of these Kings alhamdulillah
they accepted Islam but some of them
they even to the letter some of them
even trampled it beneath their feet
imagine the vers of the Quran dictated
by the
prophet they were Tor by these Kings and
some of them even trampled it beneath
the
feet and one such
letter is available in the kopake museum
in Turkey in which the prophet had
dictated the verse of the Quran of Surah
Al Imran chapter number three verse
number 64 it says
say oh people of the
book come to come in terms as between us
and you which is the first
term that we worship none but
Allah that we associate no partners with
him that we erect not among ourselves
Lords and patrons other than
Allah if then they turn back
that we are Muslims bowing our will to
Allah subhana tala this ver of the Quran
was dictated to the non-muslim Kings by
the Beloved Prophet Muhammad Salli
wasallam it's yet
available in the museum the kakei museum
in
turkey and I want to ask you the
question today there are about 14
million Arabs who are Coptic Christians
who are
Christians since Generations I'm asking
you the question which translation of
the Quran will you give to these 14
million Coptic Arab
Christians do you want to translate the
Arabic Quran into Arabic again you'll
have to give the original
text to these Christian
Arabs who understand Arabic as a
language Arabic is a mother tongue which
translation will you give will you give
the uddu translation will you give the
English translation you have to give the
original of Allah subhana tala in Arabic
that's the reason I personally prefer
along with the translation give the
original Arabic text and the Quran was
revealed for the whole of humankind and
the last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him was sent as a
messenger to the whole of
humankind there are many Muslims who
say that the Quran
is meant to be read with understanding
only by the alims only by the
scholars a lay man Muslim should not try
to understand the Quran the Quran is
meant to be read with understanding only
by the alims only by the
scholars I started my talk by quoting a
verse of the
Quran which is also recited by thear in
the of the
program which occurs in Surah Kamar
chapter number 54 no less than four
times Surah CH 54 verse number 17 verse
number 22 verse number 32 and verse
number
40 we have made the Quran easy for you
to understand and memorize then which of
you shall not receive
admonition Allah subhana tala our
creator says that we have made the Quran
easy for you to understand then which of
you shall not receive admonition Allah
says in the Quran in several places in
several verses including Surah Bak
chapter number two verse number
242 so that they will
understand Allah says inah chapter
number 15 verse number
one that is LAM raw these are the verses
of the Quran that make things clear to
you so Allah subhana is saying that this
Quran we have made it easy for you to
understand Allah says so that they
understand Allah says we have revealed
the versy of the Quran so that it will
make things clear to you so who will you
obey who will you follow those Muslims
who say that the Quran was only only
meant for the scholars to understand it
or should we follow the guidance of the
Creator Allah subhana wa ta'ala that it
was made easy for the human beings to
understand